القصه الطبيب الذي انقذ الطفله التي تعرضت
لحاله الاختناق بسبب
بلعها لغطاء زجاجه زجاجه مياه بلاستيكيه
من عمان ينضم الينا طبيب الكويتي الذي
انقذ هذه الطفله الدكتور يعقوب العصيمي
بيض الله وجهك يا دكتور
وشاكر لك انا
بشخصي انا اليوم اقول هذا هو الكويتي مو
هو اللي يسافر مو هو اللي لا هذه هذه
المواقف اكيد يعني
الرحمه الالهيه وضعتك في طريق هذه الطفله
لكن انت حديث تخرج واكيد مارست لكن هي
لحظه ما بين التردد وما بين انقاذها كيف
جاءت
في البدايه انا اشكرك اخوي عادل على كلامك
الطيب اصبح عليك وعلى الاستاذه راويه
بالخير صباح الخير على الساده المشاهدين
واهدي تخرجي الى مقام سيدي ووالدي حضره
صاحب السمو الامير نواف الاحمد الجابر
الصباح والى وي عادي الامين
سمول شيخ
احمد جابر الصباح
طال عمرك انا تخرجت وكان لازم ارجع
الكويتة لكل الشباب ارجعوا للكويت لكن انا
صراحه كنت تعبان من اختبارات الفاينل
الاختبارات الاخيره حق كليه الطب
فقررت اني ااجل شوي رجعتي قلت اربع ثلاث
ايام ارتاح فيهم
وسبحان الله كنت طالع للسوق ابي اشتري
شنطه على اساس اشيل اغراضي واودع اربد
واودع الاردن وارجع الى ديرتي واهلي في
الكويت سبحان الله وانا ما اعرف السوق
قاعده تمشي صدفه اني سمعت صراخ ابو او شذي
فاول ما طليت سبحان الله انتبهت ان كان في
زجاجه ماي ما كان عليه خطا اذا تنتبه على
الطاوله
فاحنا دارسين وعارفين انه غالبا واغلب
حالات الاختناق تكون بسبب غطاء
وانتبهت على الطفله كانت حاطه يدها حوالين
رقبتها اذا منتبه هذا دلاله واضحه انك كان
في اختناق
وبلش يطلع عليها وجهه يكون احمر
الحمد لله اللي الله سخرني والحمد لله
اللي الله قادني وفضل علي ومن علي اني
اكون موجود في هذه اللحظه اني انقذ روح
بشريه الحمد لله ما كنت مسافر يعني سبحان
الله اخرت سفرك علشان تنقذ حياه بالفعل
دكتور يعقوب طيب دكتور انت استعملت
تفضل الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول لا
تموت نفسك حتى تستوي في اجلها وهذا اجلها
وهذا موعدها والحمد لله اني كنت سبب الحمد
لله الحمد لله طيب دكتور انت استخدمت
الهايملك او مناوره كما يقال لحتى انك
تقدر تخلص البنت الصغيره من او الطفله من
حاله الاختناق اشرح لنا اكثر لانه حتى هذه
المناوره دقيقه نوعا ما واستخدامها على
الاطفال مختلف عن استخدامها على البالغين
هذه بشكل عام تحتاج صراحه تدريب ميداني اي
تكون الضغط حواليه فوق السره تحديدا على
المعده الضغط اللي داخل ثم الى اعلى هذا
الشيء راح يسبب بالضغط على الرئه الضغط
على الرئه راح يولد الضغط الى اعلى على
حوالين القصبات الهوائيه فبالتالي يزال
جسم العالق في البلعوم انا صراحه بس احب
انوه انه يعني العلامات اللي تظهر على
الحالات الاختناق هي كالتالي
في البدايه راح نشوف انه يحاول يكح يحاول
يصدرك على الشباب الاردنيين
فقالب ما راح يقدر يطلعها فممكن ينتقل
للحاله الثانيه اللي هي انه راح يحمر
وجهها او يزرق
واذا لا قدر الله ما تمت المساعده راح
ندخل في الغيبوبه او الاغماء ومن ثم اذا
لا قدر الله يعني ما وجد المساعده لا قدر
الله وبعيد الشر وتتحول حاله الى وفاه انا
بصراحه عبر قناتكم عبر قناه العربيه ادعوا
الجميع انه يبادر في الالتحاق في دورات
الطوارئ جدا مهمه والله العظيم ما تاخذ
خمس ساعات انا انا هذا ودي اسئله اليوم هل
هي مهمه ولا كماليه يا يعقوب يعني اليوم
الناس يقول لك انا ما راح احتاجها ليش اخذ
دوره اسعافات اوليه ليش ياخذ هذه الدوره
الطوارئ باختصار اذا تكرمت
والله يا ابن الحلال اللي تمر عليك حاله
واحده في حياتك فهذا انجاز لانه الله
سبحانه وتعالى يقول في كتابه ومن احياها
فكانما احيا الناس جميعا
فتخيل انك تحي حاله من الاله فهمت فانا
الصراحه ادعي يعني ان ان تكون ماده مضافه
للثانويه او المتوسطه او تكون حتى من بين
رخص فتح المحلات التجاريه انه يجب على
الموظفين يكونون عندهم دورات والموضوع
بسيط وسهل جدا سهل جدا يعني ممكن بساعتين
ثلاثه وبس وممارسين الصحيين يقدرون يقومون
في هذا الدور
والله شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور وانت مثال عن
جد يعني طيب ويحتدى به في
بمساعده الاخرين واستخدام يعني هذا
الخلفيه الطبيه لانقاذ حياه الناس شكرا
جزيلا لك الطبيب الكويتي الذي انقذ الطفله
مبارك ايضا هلا على تخرج ترى بدري الكويت
واسال الله يوفقك ان شاء الله دكتور يعقوب
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقاريات تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات